how's it going guys welcome back to a
video on code tech and tutorials today I
want to show you all something that I
found that is a super super cool I'm not
the first person to cover it in its
diligent engine now what this is is
actually a set of renders for pretty
much every OS so I just went ahead and
did a search there and give me a sec why
bring it over okay and what we see here
is the top hit is their actual site so
we'll just go there that sounds good and
there's some words about it and I'll
just read this real quick as an intro
diligent engine diligent engine is a
lightweight cross-platform graphics API
abstraction library it is designed to
take full advantage of directed 3d
twelve Vulcan and metal while supporting
older platforms via direct3d 11 OpenGL
and OpenGL ES dilatant engine exposes
common front-end API and uses hlsl as a
universal shading language on all
platforms and rendering backends
platform specific shader representations
JSL DX bytecode or spur v can be used
with corresponding backends the engine
is intended to be used as a graphics
subsystem in a game engine or any other
3d application full source code is
available on github it is distributed
under the Apache 2 license and it's free
to use Wow
ok so let's just go ahead and jump right
to get home and take a look so now what
I want to do is basically just show you
how you can run this anyone can run this
it's free it's open source so if you're
learning and studying 3d or coding this
is an excellent thing to study probably
one of the best things you can do it's
gonna be better than going to any class
probably you know everybody's different
but I think anybody who wants to learn
to just jump in so we're gonna have to
go ahead and clone and do it and do the
thing you know run it for you so the
first thing we're gonna do is just copy
this
and then we're gonna open fork for our
github access and I've already cloned it
and what I did is I just went to a file
clone and then just hit clone I made
sure I put it where I wanted to be in
the parent folder so do that if you need
to so since I've already cloned it it's
just right here and I have the latest
version and if they make any updates I
can just open fork and do a pool on the
master and if I see something cool or I
want to fix I can but you know that's
github so now that we have it we're just
gonna go to its directory I don't think
they work has a way to do that would be
really cool they did can we no I don't
see the way to do it there might be but
so we're gonna close fork now that we've
got it fort and we're just gonna go
straight to see make so we're launching
see make here and I've already done this
too so basically what you want to do
I'll go ahead and just clear it though
I'll do delete cache so basically you
browse to the source so I went to where
I had it stored source repos diligent
engine okay and then so that's where you
want to browse source - it's just the
root of it and build well everybody does
this differently I from the root hit a
new folder and made a build folder and
then went into that that's what I like
to do but it's wherever you want to
build all the objects and stuff when you
can buy all the code so then we just
basically had generate here and we're
using visual studio 16 2019 so this is
Visual Studio Community Edition 2019 and
no changes here used to falta native
compilers and will let it do its thing
and it'll give us all the message that
there see make us set up and it looks
like right here they tell you what your
platform supports so as you can see we
support everything but GL s GL ES and
metal medals for
what am I trying to say medals for Apple
stuff and GL es is for mobile so we're
on a Windows desktop so that's why we've
got these here alright so now that it's
all done so generating done gave us some
more messages about spur v finding it
and we're just going to go ahead and hit
the open project since everything
completed with no errors and that will
open visual studio 2019 and this is
actually it and we don't see anything
because it's off to the side so let's
just look at it alright so climb so
everything here and it looks like
they've got a whole bunch of solutions
within this project for visual studio
they've got asteroids which I assume is
some kind of example there's a unity
we've got tools samples FX and a core
and these are all individual projects
I'm guessing they have most of them
build as static libraries I'm not really
sure we could look though yeah this is a
static library so that means other
projects within this can link to it
that's a DLL so if you can you can in
case you don't know if you're making
libraries within Visual Studio you can
link to them with your other projects
and well there's so much you can do I'm
not going to go over all that but
basically what we can do is we can find
any of these that are executables such
as I think this gltf viewer is all these
samples are probably executables cuz
they're examples of how to run it that
one's an executable this atmosphere
let's take a look at it also an
executable so all these samples are
probably gonna be executables so what
you can do if you want to run any of
them you can right-click on it and do
set a start up project it starts off
with this gltf viewer but we could
switch it to other ones by going like so
and then just hitting play if you want I
couldn't change these you can but I'm
just leaving it default for the sake of
simplicity here so this is a default one
I'm going to go ahead and show you that
real quick so we're gonna set it as a
start up project it build
to do its thing it's going to take a
moment
and it pops up a window in it it asks us
what back in we want you so we use
Vulcan gl DirectX 12 or 11 so that's
super cool it's only using three
megabytes of memory
let's choose let's choose walking so I
clicked walk in there it looks like it's
starting to load stuff as you can see
the memory is it's chunking up there and
there we are bring that back up okay
just want to be able to see those meters
on the side so it looks like it gives us
a helmet and some nice nice lighting and
there are other models we can choose
here and we can change the light
direction and this is a model rotation
and here's all the other settings you
can do so this is just that first demo
it looks like they've got all kinds of
cool stuff going on all right it's all
kinds of little tests with the lighting
and yeah so you can really get a good
look at your object with all these
different rendering techniques
transparency looks like that okay base
color mesh normals specular IPL it looks
really nice diffuse ivl that looks kind
of cool too so there's just so much to
play around with here so let's close
this one and let's run asteroids I'm
gonna go ahead and set asteroids is
startup project looks like it's all on
its own just at the very bottom so it
might be like a little bit of an easter
egg extra thing that somebody was just
doing or the developer was just doing so
let's go ahead and do that when we build
I assume we're gonna get some asteroids
going on
looks like it's doing some yeah it's
just showing us everything it's building
here creating 1000 meshes okay so it did
some stuff and it is clearly just
asteroids going across a asteroid like
sky or skybox what is it a belt oh
consumed out and I can see it looks like
an asteroid belt oh that's super cool I
thought it was going to be like a
make of the asteroids game or something
but this is super awesome too so it
tells us what happened here and what's
doing very cool and that's performing
decently for that many objects okay so
that's basically a thousand objects all
moving that's not that's not too bad for
a thousand objects moving alright so
that's pretty much it so so you can use
these examples I've showed you here if
you have any questions let me know below
let me know if you're able to get it to
run and let me know what you take away
from this this is wow I'm overwhelmed
with how cool this is so I just had to
share alright take it easy guys stay
safe and I'll see you the next one peace
out